the jurogan experience
you've always been a staunch advocate
for free speech even when that speech is
hate speech
and uh that's a that's a very uh
it's a difficult argument for people to
have in this day and age because
people want to ban hate speech they want
to ban people from talking
you've always been an advocate for free
speech and saying that like
even though it seems like it's a good
idea to ban these ideas or to ban people
discussing these things
in fact it actually turns out to be a
terrible idea
well you see when people say they want
to ban
hate speech what they mean is they want
to ban the speech that
they hate yes but if you
allowed something called hate speech
to be banned then the only important
question
would be who decides and
again if the government is going to be
the one to decide
what hate speech to ban it's not going
to be the same
speech as the speech you hate it's going
to be the speech
they hate um think if
again for liberals who are very hot
these days about banning
hate speech what they mean is they want
to ban
speech that is bigoted against people
based on skin color
or based on sex or based on religion
that's what they mean by hate speech
but what i always ask liberals is
well what makes you think you're going
to have the power to decide
what's hateful you're never the ones who
are going to have the power
what would happen if the guy who decided
what speech to hate and then was joe
mccarthy
he would abandon your speech what if it
was
giuliani who tried unsuccessfully
when he was mayor of new york to ban art
in the brooklyn museum of art that he
didn't like
because he thought it was disrespectful
of his religion
and he hated that speech now the speech
he hated
wasn't the same speech that i hated the
speech he hated
wasn't the same speech as uh as liberals
or progressives hated
but he was the one who got to decide not
they
um and that's you know that's the
problem that's really why hate speech
cannot be a category uh that is allowed
to ban
because it all depends on who's going to
decide
and what they hate it's not going to be
the same as what you hate
in the 1990s there was a big move on a
lot of college campuses
to ban hate speech and what they meant
by that is they wanted to ban racist
speech
and a lot of black students were in
favor of it and
i i was then the head of the aclu and i
used to go around
speaking to these audiences and i had a
a very substantial reputation
as being an advocate for racial justice
and affirmative action
and and uh and all that uh
so i was sort of on their side and they
knew that
uh in terms of the substance but i use
i didn't preach to them about the first
amendment i used to ask those black
students
if you succeed in getting your
university
to ban hate speech what do you think is
going to happen next
do you think you're going to be the ones
to decide or do you think
the board of trustees is going to be the
ones to decide
and the board of trustees are white and
the board of trustees don't share your
politics
and the truth of the matter is if if
there had been hate speech codes
on college campuses in the 1960s their
most frequent
victim would have been malcolm x not
david duke
and the kids would look at me like they
had never thought of it that way
but that's the problem the problem is
always who gets to define
what's hateful and who gets to decide
what to ban and it isn't often going to
be the ones
who advocate for these codes
um you know the same thing happened in
england in 1973 when
when the national student union banned
hate speech
uh banned racist speech from
college campuses in in england and
a group of zionist kids
who were among the leaders of the
national student movement
at the time uh were all for that
and then a few years later a very few
years later
um uh the the the students
changed they were different students
deciding and they decided to ban
a zionist speaker on the grounds they
they said that zionism was a form of
racism
well the zionist kids who had supported
those hate speech bans
they didn't think that zionism was a
form of racism
but a few years later a majority of the
national student union
did so think and so the very hate speech
bands
that these kids supported ended up being
used
against their own speakers
there are hundreds of examples like that
and the reason why
these bands don't work is
is that nobody can define
what hate speech is and it all ends up
coming down
to who decides and most often it ain't
you
yeah i mean i can completely understand
the position that a social media company
would have
where they wouldn't want to have what
they consider hate speech
on their platform because they think it
reflects poorly on them and they also
think that it um
it radicalizes young people it gets
young people
to to think along the same lines if
they're
very charismatic and they're enticing
they could get young people to grow
join what they believe are hate groups
but
so is the solution just leave everything
up and let everybody just kind of duke
it out in the town square of ideas
well i i i think so and the reason
i think that is that the only
alternative
is to give somebody the power to decide
what should be excluded from the town
square
and who is that somebody right you know
i don't think you can get out of that
dilemma
um uh you know at the very beginning of
our history
uh when the first amendment was first
invented uh we all learned in school
that that people like james madison and
tom jefferson
and the rest of them were all the super
advocates of free speech and first
amendment
but they weren't um a lot of them
believed
that the first amendment did not protect
full speech
because the way the same way that people
how about
about hate speech is well what is the
virtue of false speech
why does full speech contribute anything
uh to a rational discussion
how does false speech enhance democracy
so they there was largely a consensus at
the beginning
of the 18th at the uh uh end of the 18th
century
uh when when the country began there was
largely a
a consensus even among the
the the the the fiercest advocates of
free speech that false speech was not
protected by the first amendment
then under john adams presidency
the second president of the united
states um
they passed something called the alien
institution act
and this was a federal statute that
congress passed
and it it um
it made it a crime to say
false things critically false things
about the president and
the problem was is that it was the
president
who decided to whom that law should
apply
so it ended up that people who were
critical of john adams including
a member of congress including several
editors of newspapers
including you know lots of people who
they
they were arrested and convicted and
sent to jail
under this and why did that happen it
happened
because the people in charge said that
their speech was false
the speech of the people that they
prosecuted
and you know when people think of true
or false
they think of things like well if you
say two plus two is five
we know that two plus two is four so
two plus two is five is false but in the
world of politics
almost everything can be interpreted as
true or false depending on who the
speaker and who the listener is
look at what just happened with with our
elections
um 70 of people in this
among republicans believe that the
election was fraudulent
now you can argue about whether that's
true or whether that's false
but do you really want to make it a
crime
for people to say that the election was
fraudulent
you have to fight it out you have to
duke it out
um otherwise you're going to end up
using these bans as weapons
to use against people you don't agree
with
by simply claiming that what they said
was false
that was the history in the in the early
part
of of uh of the american experiment
and it's same the thing is true today
about hate speech or bigoted speech or
any other kind of speech
you know you the price we pay
for having the freedom to speak and
listen
and argue is that some of the stuff
we have to hear is ugly
and it's like an insurance policy
and what we're insuring against is if we
don't want to hear the ugly speech if we
want to ban
ugly speech we give the government the
power to decide what's ugly enough to be
banned
and then we'll lose our own rights to
free speech for sure
and there i don't think there's any way
out of that
um it's not intuitive you know i used to
say i
i was a kid who grew up in the streets
of brooklyn if somebody called me a
dirty jew
uh or insulted my mother or
or anything else i mean there were two
responses
you didn't argue with i didn't know
about free speech when i was 11 years
old on the streets in brooklyn
uh if somebody insulted you or said
something bigoted to you
you had two choices you punched them out
or you ran
if they were bigger than you or there
was more of them than you
uh free speech is an acquired taste
it's something you learn about later um
it's something i didn't understand
really
really until i got to the aclu and began
to come to grips with these kinds of
problems we're discussing now
was it an easy thing to come to grips
with or did you go back and forth with
it like was this like a
no it's it's it's not an easy thing to
come to grips with because it's not
intuitive
i mean you know the first time i saw
um
people from the klan talking or
neo-nazis talking my first instinct
was i wanted to take a club and beat
them over the head i mean how could
how could your first instinct not be
that
but i began to see that the consequences
of that
was to give the government
which was often going to be
in the hands of people that didn't like
what i believed
to give the government the power to
decide who to beat over the head
and for what speech and i began to see
pretty quickly as you come to grips with
these in real life cases
that if you give the government the
power to decide
what speech is ugly enough to be banned
it will
as often be your speech as it will be
the speech that you don't like and that
powerless people
people who are discriminated against uh
black people women gay people jews
muslims uh political minorities
socialists uh communists
whatever those are never the people who
get to decide what speech to ban
they are the victims of the speech bans
uh because the people who get to decide
are are more often as i keep saying more
often
going to be people like joe mccarthy and
richard nixon
and and uh and and trump
and and why would we want to trust
why would black lives matter protesters
want to trust their speech rights
to somebody like donald trump
why would right wing
people want to trust their speech rights
to bernie sanders say um
and you know this doesn't often just
break down on liberal
conservative lines i mean remember that
that you know in the in one of the worst
atrocities of civil liberties that this
country has ever seen
uh americans american citizens of
japanese descent
um these were not aliens these were not
immigrants
these were you know these were american
citizens of japanese descent
not one of whom was ever charged with
any thing criminal or with anything
treasonous or with anything traitorous
120 000 of them were plucked from their
jobs and their homes and their
businesses and sent off to camps for the
duration of the war for no other reason
than descended from japanese people
and this was done by franklin delano
roosevelt
you know so so the fact is you can never
trust the powerful with your civil
liberties
that's true about speech and it's true
about all civil liberties
um power is the antagonist
not not republicans not democrats
um power is the antagonist and whoever
has it
uh is a danger to civil liberties if
they're not restrained
and one of the restraints
is in the first amendment to the
constitution
which says congress shall make
no law that abridges speech
now you know no law means no law it
doesn't mean
some laws and it doesn't mean oh well
bad laws they can abridge
but but not not good laws because
you can't trust what they decide is good
and what they decide is bad
so yeah i i think
i do think you got to duke it out with
words and the line
between what's permissible and what's
not permissible
needs to be between speech and conduct
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience